RETO MEIER: Hello, everyone.
My name is Reto Meier, and
welcome to "This Week in
Android Development,"
November 16, 2012.
We've had a huge couple of weeks
in Android Development
developments, so this week's
episode is stuffed fuller than
the turducken I'll be feasting
on next week at Thanksgiving.
Earlier this week, lightning
reflexes and nerves of steel
were prerequisites for picking
up a shiny new Nexus 4, 7, or
10 when the latest members of
the Nexus family appeared,
albeit briefly, for sale
on Google Play.
You can't have a new framework
without a new API to go along
with it, so Tuesday also saw the
grand unveiling of Android
API level 17, featuring the new
Daydream API, lock screen
widgets, and improved render
script computational
performance.
A new API is no fun without a
set of new tools to use with
it, so don't forget to check out
the latest tools revision.
That's R21 for those
keeping count.
That's also available
for download now.
It features the incredibly cool
multi-config editor, more
app templates, and the new UI
automated test framework.
If all of these new releases has
inspired you to hone up on
your Android development skills
but you're not sure
where to start, check out the
newly rearranged Android
training on the Android
developer side.
It's been a busy few weeks for
Android Developers Live, too,
with the premiere of "Table
Flip" with me.
The first episode focused the
dark heat of a thousand dying
suns at apps with
exit buttons.
Check out the YouTube
video to learn why.
Later that week, Ian and I
looked at instant messaging
apps on "The App Clinic" before
Roman, Nick, and Adam
took their take on what it takes
to make the ultimate
unified messaging app.
They also invited the Android
design community to become
part of Android Design In
Action, starting with the
community hang out
and an Android
design stencil giveaway.
Then earlier today, I flew solo
for a personal fitness
app clinic, the irony of which
cannot possibly be
understated.
We're taking a break next week
as we search for Ian, who's
review of one of the less
well-reviewed GPS tracking
apps has resulted in him being
lost in the backwoods of the
Sierra Nevada forests.
Then we'll be back after
stuffing ourselves stupid with
Thanksgiving fare.
Want to help us decide
which apps to review
when we come back?
Check out our Trello board at
bit.ly/AppClinicTrello to
nominate your apps and
cast your votes.
We'll have an abbreviated lineup
on Android Developers
Live next week, as most
of our team is
traveling, cooking, or eating.
But don't forget you can find
the complete schedule for next
week's live shows at Google
Developers Live.
Today's live wallpaper was
Fancy Falling Quads from
leihwelt.com, and know that if I
didn't know better, I'd hang
my hat right there.
My name is Reto Meier,
thanks for watching.